turning now to the war in ukraine it is
day 100 of russia's war and ukraine's
president says that russian forces are
controlling 20 percent of the country an
area he describes as quote a complete
disaster ground and air assaults for
weeks have destroyed countless homes and
buildings throughout the eastern and
southern part of ukraine and thousands
of soldiers and civilians have been
killed in that bombardment mts taeyab
has this report on life in the russian
occupied city of harsan and we have to
warn you as we have so many times before
that these images may be hard to watch
hung by his wrists and put in stress
positions alexander guz a former
ukrainian military draftee says he was
tortured by russian soldiers and while
his scars are fading the memories of
what happened to him are not
they put a bag over my head and then
began beating me he says i was so
severely beaten i lost consciousness
kremlin black forces seized control of
his southern ukrainian hometown of
kursan in the early days of its invasion
since then moscow's grip on the city of
nearly 300 thousand has only tightened
with curson now an oppressive dystopia
where allegations of torture and
disappearances are widespread
through an encrypted video call we
connected with bogdan andrenko a
20-year-old volunteer providing aid to
people in need in croissant
you feel constantly under threat that
russians will come and take you away he
says a bunch of volunteers in the city
were already taken by the russians and
we don't know what happened to them you
must be at least a little bit afraid
that something might happen to you
every single day he says
[Music]
every so often video emerges from
croissant of ukrainian civilians
resisting russia's occupation
only to be met with violence those who
manage to make it out take shelter in
cities like odessa to the south where
they receive aid and other support
it's here we met olia chumachenko and
her four-year-old son kasia who fled
croissant over a month ago
i knew i had to leave the town i was
born in she says but i did it for my son
he's my only reason for living she says
now we have an update for you on those
long-range rocket systems that the
president authorized for ukraine this
week ukrainian forces are now in an
unspecified european country receiving
training on the weapons in the hopes
they can take back that territory from
russia gail
all right mts triumph in ukraine thank
you very much